turtle execute plan should borderlands
is a franchise that made fetch quests
enjoyable again for shooter fans there's
so much raw personality and character in
their worlds the by the time you finish
a mission you don't really remember what
it is you are looking for in the first
place so much is who you met along the
way the first DLC handsome jack
doppelganger pack out on November 11
keeps for this personality as content
theme Jack for those of you who haven't
played the previous Borderlands 2 is a
maniacal self-absorbed programmer who
during the course of Borderlands the
pre-sequel is in the process of
installing the Hyperion corporation as
top dog over Pandora and it's moon Elpis
Jack's doppelganger on the other hand is
just some poor sap not only forged in
Jack's likeness but due to heavy student
debt is forced to work for him and by
work for him I mean shoot moon men in
their air face bubbles Jack's main
ability is to spawn dizzy jacks which
are Holograms focused almost entirely on
damage unlike Wilhelm's more well
rounded drones wolf insane the capstone
of the hero of this story skill tree for
example spawns a badass digi jack the
first badass familiar in the borderlands
series lead writer Anthony Burch
informed GameSpot that four players all
playing as Jack's doppelganger could
potentially spawn up to 13 Jack did you
Jack combos on screen at a time that is
one big Jack Attack Jack also has some
skills that might encourage less than
good team behavior one skill commitment
sees Jack gain power as his fellow co-op
players go down in fight for your life
to make up for it another inspire allows
Jack to give rousing inspirational
speeches it's in our moments of decision
that destiny
[ __ ] the real draw of jack doppelganger
though is that he's a fully fleshed out
character with his own dialogue and take
on the events of Borderlands the
pre-sequel for example in the opening
scene real Jack becomes distracted
trying to talk to you finally arrived
hmm wow you sound really attractive
distractingly so you'll have to decide
for yourself if the season pass at
$29.99 or the standalone costs of $9.99
is worth a jacker 13 but if you didn't
connect with the main cast this may be
your chance to jump back in and/or be a
douche hey were you letting Jack babe
well nice to meet you check
[Music]